what's going on guys national master james canty
the third title tuesday double the prizes guys
let's get right into it okay nothing else that
needs to be said let's show you guys what we
have here we have title tuesday guys okay it's
gonna be actually a double the prizes this week
if you take a look at that 3200 guys fun for this
week look at that that is absolutely amazing guys
i hope you guys are ready for that it's going
to be absolutely fun right now uh the big boys
are playing today in this kind of format we have
the 11 round swiss every tuesday 10 a.m pacific
of course and uh three minutes with one second
increment guys payout is based off the chess.com
tie breaks now let's get right into it the games
have started so no enough talking guys let's get
right into the games okay we got big fellas like
hikaru nakamura as we're watching right now 3205.
look at his rating he's not playing any games but
he is playing a game but at the same time he's not
3205 guys playing uh rondo cop priscilloso from
bolivia so let's see what let's see what he's
doing actually what's going on guys welcome
to the stream cool with knight comes to c4
immediately queen is actually hitting a2 and i
can come out via the b3 square so maybe a4 but
that does weaken the b3 pawn so maybe something
like bishop a1 but he plays bishop d4 instead guys
three minute one second increment here i mean
look how much time rondo's already down here
hikaru just moves so fast guys it's absolutely
ridiculous sometimes it's really absolutely
ridiculous to be honest but uh he's up like so
much time and he has that one second increment
here so he's almost not thinking now this is
attacked here he does have some compensation
on the file here this is actually very annoying
the a2 pawn is quite annoying uh we're k1 or a4
this does make it very weak so let's see what
he comes up with maybe even something like e5 he
actually takes on f6 that was surprising but he's
actually going to hit him with e5 as a follow-up
pretty nice look at the compensation guys
you always have to try to make it as uh
as complicated as possible he carver does a
great job of doing that so after uh bishop
takes f6 and he i don't know why he's thinking so
long about this one you got to take with either
either one right pawn takes just messes up the
structure bishop takes and allowed him to play
e5 but he did take this way and let him mess
up the structure a4 is now followed as well
this pawn is very weak it's hard to get to it's
defend it she would have to attack this knight and
attack this pawn at the same time but you only
move one move at a time so it may not work here
rick to d3 now we over protect it maybe moving the
knight back to c4 at the same time doubling the
rooks on the weak d6 pawn here as rondo is down to
50 under a minute now about 50 seconds we do have
that one second increment which is very important
you can't just be flagged in one second increment
it can happen but most times it doesn't happen
it doesn't happen in this one second increment
and here we go hitting the d6 pawn now you have
to give uh some props to rondo here playing
really strong honestly he has uh you know played
really good as you see you got double rooks here
like he's making real legit threats against here
but it may not it just it just doesn't seem like
enough he plays rook f3 hitting two separate pawns
guys and defending all at the same time very very
strong stuff here knight takes d6 he actually
played king f1 instead very interesting move
very interesting he didn't take the pawn guys
he just didn't take it maybe he'll take it now
maybe not he doesn't take the pawn h4 i guess he's
just saying it's gonna stay here but rookie six
can just defend it i wonder what he has in mind
take it now
there we go okay oh my goodness there it is takes
and takes perfect oh my goodness he hung a rook
that's it or he hang he hung the exchange not
a whole brook here but this one's going to be
a resignable game there it is the resignation
and that game's over that game is already
over here guys as you take a look at the
standings here hikaru we got misha nick look
at all the red here of course it is title
tuesday so you're only going to see red but
you see all the gm's lined up here gm gm gm
gm just like it's it's ridiculous how strong
these guys in here fm sub josh my buddy josh is
playing iams in the chat i mean there's there's
a lot of people here guys liam lee look at him
playing this is awesome to see this live awesome
to see it live we do have more games of course
let's go to the next one here fair shape fear
chest on youtube and sketch cough underscore v
looks like of course white's losing here
there's a resignation very quick that one
happened he's done four he's done four
let's go to operon grandmaster o'byrne
what's going on usually when you get
to a position you have to see what
what everything looks like before you actually
say it was better first okay well we have
five pawns five pawns two bishops this is a
bishop pair versus not having the bishop here
now he can remove the bishop here and he does so
but there is some checks and some annoyance here
he plays knight d6 check instead and the knight
to ca game's over instantly tactics win games oh
my goodness get him off the board start a new one
that's not a move send the stretcher and the rit
knight takes b6 rook d7 and let's just have a nice
day let's get this off the screen this is a family
channel knight c5 is going to take on b3 we can
just do it this way it probably will take longer
so let's just take on h6 he could have kg7 rook h4
rook takes c6 is not a move because knight d4 ouch
so he plays here with knight f6 as the
intention king to d3 hitting the knight
knight f6 anyway first might as well and that's
a wrap start a new game hey what's up nmcanty
what's up oregon big red welcome this is a
family channel luke star i mean come on now
come on come on now okay so uh benjamin bach
another strong grandmaster guys you're gonna get
nothing but the best chest today we definitely
have a double the prizes as well so i hope you
guys are ready double the prizes are here you have
to be titled are you titled you could join you can
still join you have time black one if you're
a title player you can um you definitely can
you definitely can join let's
play another gm hey there big
bro what's up keith what's going on
man how are you bro good to see you
check this looks like a i don't know
it looks like a draw but expectively
honestly no objectively because these pawns and
you actually can uh queen here so yeah this is a
win because you can queen we have the bishop that
we need to queen on this square so it's not a draw
and look at this i mean look at this beautiful
play where does the knight go have you ever seen
a position like this where the knight can't go
anywhere have to sacrifice it come around this
way the back way and that's a wrap just like that
i mean decisive games everywhere guys this is like
oh my goodness there are no draws today nobody is
taking draws today this is strong chess today guys
how many players do we have in today's tournament
634 players wow yeah can and play absolutely
nm's can play cm's can play fm i am gm hi canty
what's going on gold roof welcome to the stream
let's go hey james speedy indian welcome to the
street just be the indian check rookie six is
cool oh maybe a draw no you can't do that he
got two seconds left three seconds king g3
oh oh don't repeat oh what you can't really
flag yeah this is three one so i would i was
playing on for the flag but i forgot it was three
seconds and one second so you can't not that you
can't flag but it's much harder to flag in
this time control as you see guys the time
keeps going up they may think that you have
no time but in reality you actually have time
wow oh my goodness oh my goodness get the man off
the board send a stretcher to his address he gonna
need one send him a call or something guys well
swindle of the year right here oh my goodness how
do you do that well it's done it's because of time
trouble time trouble gets a song that's not a move
oh my goodness he jumped he definitely jumped
the jedi what's up gmc welcome to the stream
ouch that's here family show get it off the board
you're right speedy india my bad let me get that
off the board we got kids watching here that is
nasty there push oh we have a draw guys if pushing
we have the philidor position you're keeping him
on the third rank this is the phillidor position
so if you can look it up if you don't know
about it you should know about it this is
how you draw a rook in game keep the rook on the
ring just keep it back and forth back and forth
cool you can even trade it now and then you walk
the king up uh precisely always straight back
opposition get in front of the pawn straight back
go up yep straight back in opposition opposition
okay you could you could go right here absolutely
straight back up and up again straight back and
there it is a draw guys a lot of you guys will
mess this up in the chat so you have to make sure
straight back and opposition no matter which
way he goes so if he goes this way opposition
this way if it goes this way opposition this way
if you're asking why can't he push the pawn well
he can but then it's just a draw now and there's
no move for black so that is draw 101 hopefully
you guys know how to do that that would be great
as round two should be starting soon should be
starting here look at all these ones here guys
a lot of ones and there it is round two is just
now picking up we're going to take a look at a few
games or all of them as we can here we go hikaru
fan favorite we always want to watch ikaru play
right always want to watch ikaru play i've never
lost a drawing game in game and i never will
that's to see okay nice nice very nice attitude
to have there and statement cast was out the way
knight f6 so he carved plays and this is a modern
but he he's a kings indian player as well he's
been playing a lot of modern especially in blitz
chess and he's very excellent with these setups
guys a lot of times you remove the knight you play
f5 and f4 and then you play h6 and g5 do something
with the bishop and you actually pawn storm
uh he has some very great games in in this in this
manner there it is knight to d7 followed by f5 and
f4 guys he's gonna pawn storm very quickly and
as you know he carbo plays really fast he's 3205
that's an understatement he should be higher right
and then three minutes in one second increment
on this guys so let's see what happens knight
to d7 more in a king's indian fashion from
a modern defeat from a modern defense
it's almost like he's playing sort of
king's indian against everything king's indian
for life and c3 cecil c3 sicilian for the kill
it's actually c3 cecilia you drop the iliad drop
the alien sicilian drop the alien that's right c3
still for the kill speedy indian absolutely that's
our favorite opening pawn takes and rook takes ca5
he plays knight c5 instead because this pawn
like we're always going to get this he doesn't
worry about it at all e4 is hanging and not
really it's just attacked but not hanging
f5 was played guys and white's doing a great
job of kind of restricting a little bit you may
see something like queen e8 eventually maybe
even h6 well h6 doesn't work we just take it
but you do have to watch out for this too as well
i'm sure carl sees that there are no immediate
night jumps besides knight b5 it doesn't do much
if you could do something in the center that would
be great but unfortunately it's blocked so you
can't do anything there as his time winds down
hit carlos plays fast he's really strong
what's up gizmeister welcome to the stream
you know so uh with the big boy chester guys we're
gonna stick on this game here to see what happens
rick takes a5 is the last move his wife tries
to figure out what to do and even after knight
b5 i think it just hangs upon here rick takes a4
and we're good to go bishop to h5 on the board
three minutes one second increment so this was
interesting let's go back and see that again
takes takes bishop h5 that's an interesting move
i wonder what the intention is for this um i don't
really know oh queen eight okay he's just stopping
my queen eight move that's that's just he thought
about that one like he really thought about that
one that's pretty good mr page five stopping queen
eight because that was the movie wanted to make
so you may have to settle with queen to d7 now
today's a break from us qualifier yes yes thank
you guys in the chat bishop f6 now trying to get
rid of this bishop we're probably gonna or we are
going to take on f6 he plays bishop h6 and now we
have the rook on the file here but now it's not
the type of attack that we thought we would be
getting as black here or the attack that we wanted
to have maybe we could play f4 and allow him to
take so that this rook will have access to this
rank now due to the fact that we capture on c5
it's forced by the way the bishop is trapped it
does give us a square for the knight to go to
as well they can even swing into h4 and g2 you
also have moves like queen f8 queen g7 just to
be a little bit annoying here he plays knight g6
did not expect this one at all actually knight
to g6 well now knight h4 is still annoying he
plays knight to d7 instead these are very hard
to predict the moves with hikaru of course and
car which is like different plans like what is
this even doing 1957 he moves out of the way we're
going to see in a minute or so though e4 maybe 95.
light square bishop gets to e6 are you talking
about this way could be annoying maybe he's
trying to stop that maybe for now let's stop
by say thank you for teaching them how to throw
so uh nice that's what's up i think that's
what knight g6 is for yeah bishop g5
it's a good move actually that's a really good
move for knight f4 i'm assuming what's this move
doing uh revealing here but he's down on time
guys you have to pay attention like we was using
we were saying this a lot in the us champs online
qualifier you have to use the clock as a piece
you have to use the clock as a piece so instead
of having 16 pieces when you set up all your pawns
and your pieces all together 16 pieces you need
to add one and one more which is the clock and
here 42 seconds here is not going to cut it
against hikaru nakamura i mean this position
may even be you know like slightly equal maybe
slightly better for black of course especially
with the rook file and stuff like that but with
not enough time it doesn't matter does not matter
love your commentary really helps to get my
mind into the masterminds thank you wonder puppy
welcome to the stream hope you're doing well title
tuesday guys doubled the prices here and the big
boys are playing today we have ikaru nakamura
and many other gm's guys many other gm's so
look out and don't go anywhere knight to d4
wait what just happened he just went back to d4
yeah that my mind is right i was
like did he just hang a piece but
what is the i the idea bro wow i guess pawn takes
you're hitting this pawn you're hitting the knight
so if pawn takes knight yeah he took on
a5 he didn't take the piece that must have
been strong nicey what is going on right now
the this is pinned but you can't take this
so he takes here so he lost in exchange but he's
getting it right back with interest geez tactics
win games oh my goodness e4 knight takes you
getting mated in a few it feels like you're
getting mated in a few knight f3 doesn't work you
do have knight d2 that's a great move guys knight
d2 is really cool knight d2 knight f3 anyway he
plays knight to c3 directly hitting the queen
so knight f3 is check anyway because we have the
protection with our queen here and 10 seconds for
fahad here very strong though he's international
master here from bangladesh how important is it
to coordinate your knight one thousand percent
important uh it depends on what piece you're
using maybe you're using the bishop with it oh
my goodness this oh man oh this hurts oh man
yikes just combo after combo come on can we
have some mercy on some of these players hikaru
okay operon is playing black here it looks
like he's in trouble though king g6 rook h8
rook h rook h8 is mate this is the
and you can even go this way either way
yikes yeah black is definitely lost here
no way around this it's good to know the
coordination of the pieces it usually takes three
or more pieces for a successful attack
beating a strong i am getting one elo yeah
that's the life of ikaru right you know yeah
i just beat a 2900 got two points you know
three points absolutely insane another level
half man half everything else bishop f6 rook h
8 is going to be mate if king f7 then there's rook
h7 followed by king g or e6 if think of king e8
you would want to go king e6 to cut off the king
d7 escape square here but 10 seconds for mom chill
petkov but it's actually he's not going to flag
this is three minutes to one second increment
reagan qc thanks for the sub eight months eight
months says let's have some good chess that's
right today definitely going to be excellent chess
rick takes d5 and king to g6 should be game over
start a new game big fella start a new game it
doesn't matter i'll take with the bishop doesn't
matter what you do i go right back and rook h8
and there it is resignation g g great game great
game let's take a look at the standings
here take a look at standings twos and carl
at one point it started turning
like 32.05 got one point out of that
fair chess on youtube is three thousand as
well we got a couple of three thousands in here
liam lay vincent kymer very strong strong gm young
look at all these players guys i mean this is the
best kind of chess you get to see here you know
it's exciting let's go on to this next game some
other gm is playing a strong national master here
g4 he's playing good honestly looks like a draw
he has to be careful bishop d1 knight
f6 it looks like a draw the idea is to
as soon as i can trade off this pawn if i'm able
to no you can't lose both h5 should be good now
yeah h5 would have gave him probably a little bit
of hope if i could trade off one pawn i'm going to
sack my bishop for the other that's the idea here
max what's up max max milne in the chat here's his
h5 move did she oh i was about to did he flag you
can't be doing that don't scare yourself like that
you do have that one second increment there
should be no reason to be flagging here
what is he doing time trouble getting him now
he didn't lost the pawn yeah x bishop e8 i guess
yeah this is losing let's see the technique guys
now you should be able to push both of these
he missed he definitely messed this up he could
have had a chance for a draw i think but now these
pawns are mobile and going crazy he goes he has to
stay on this diagonal for any type of hope yikes
yeah that's a wrap that's over bishop three king
takes he was going for one last little trick and
there it is game's over yikes time trouble though
time trouble got him that's exactly what happened
guys as round three is about to start round three
starts in a few thanks for the sub appreciate it
okay let's go to the next game guys hikaru
and chess lover both have two points here we
go hikar will show us something nice here
flexibility and knight f3 we don't know
what he's going to play yet and then
he plays his usual stuff honestly b3
usually sometimes he'll play it first this is the
larson system guys and it's an offbeat opening
that throws people off and it's also an attacking
opening as weird as it is as weird as it may look
it's also a very it's an attacking opening so
kind of weird let's see how he attacks here
bishop e2 bishop to b2 you play c4 i'm an e4 for
life kind of guy but at the same time um it's very
nice to see this did he just hang upon he does
have knight no he doesn't yeah he's hung upon
hanging upon against his cargo is not going
to get you anywhere this could be over already
what's the best way to start chess as a beginner
well one of the it's like you know a few steps
number one is definitely play you have to play you
have to keep playing and the reason why you have
to play is get the experience but what's good
what's not you know what do you like what don't
you like you know what positions are you getting
and you start catering it to positions you like
and start learning openings and um and
uh games and players that play like you
lightsabers on let's write masculine and another
thing to do um for as a beginner is to study study
all parts of your game opening middle tactics
tactics being big events big emphasis on tactics
is that not a zucker tour no it was
not observatory it was close though
very close but this is a ready nimso larson
already nemzo larsen here not a big fan of
these positions myself i am e4 for life
i love attacking chess not not that you
can't get attacking chess from here but i'm
just more familiar with those positions and
bobby fischer you know a lot of stuff like just
e4 for life hey big fella oh mid what's up man
and hakeem what's going on guys bishop to f3
after bishop takes f3 knight takes f3 here
let's just see the technique that hikaru uses
in this game to see what happens this pawn
runs down here to create some weaknesses but it's
actually very solid with the pawn defending the
queen defending the rook is defended so this is
not even anything to worry about that's why the
bishop is on c3 as well a3 doesn't really matter
for us it's also actually a weakness so honestly
his best bet will be trading these off because
this could become a weakness if he's not careful
queen to e4 interesting move pretty good i like it
i like queen e4 guys queenie 4 is kind of annoying
it's forcing an issue in a way maybe queen c1
that's passive queen takes c4 plays queen e2
this out of the way no queen trade because
it feels like black has a slight initiative
they get a strong knight on e4 still have
the file here some pressure on the a file
not a smart trade so he plays queen e2 c5 to kind
of lock the position down a little bit and we do
have a trade we could take this he says no don't
want to double the pawns mess up the structure
so let's just go rook d1 get him off the board
get him off the boy here he goes back rook a8
yeah he's playing really strong chess lover
108 international master here from zybarian
all right by yen i forgot i said but yeah he's uh
very strong international master playing pretty
good to be honest i mean this is not a dominant
game that you usually would see from nakamura
not dominant but we do prefer white they do
have a very strong file i love this knight now
f3 is not a move guys by the way e3 is hanging
it feels like the queen's trap but it's not
very interesting move i think the idea guys
is this knight d7 followed by knight f6 which
make for something like knight h5 or knight to
e8 making the knight very very weird looking
yeah he's in the think tank and there it is
knight h5 guys 95 is on the board we would
love to kick it it's called removing
the defender that would be h3 and g4
that's going to take some time though i don't
think this could realistically work he might
be going for it okay okay karu okay yeah he's
listening no i'm actually just feeling good that
he made the move that i thought h3 and g4 and the
knight has to move somewhere but maybe knight d7
first because knight f6 is a possibility right now
so you would want to play something like knight
to d7 a3 makes sense we could just go queen to c3
bring the queen a little bit closer into the game
queen a1 is ridiculous but it can be played
but queen c3 keeps the same the same um same
threat there it is queen to c3 on the board thanks
wonder probably appreciate it appreciate you there
okay thanks
appreciate it also follow the big fella thanks
max thanks we missed a few moves here let's go
back queen c3 knight f6 and f3 queen f5 so i'm
wondering maybe e4 just makes another hole so
maybe no e4 so he actually moves knight back
to d3 instead appreciate it sub casey what's
up omni your commentary is easy for a newbie like
me to understand thanks for your effort i'm loving
loving the love here appreciate it absolutely
glad i can help if anything let me know we in
here rook to d8 and rick to d2 i'm telling you
guys this guy is playing really strong against
just feels like he icarus more space again like
we talked about right this pawn being a weakness
so if we trade as hikaru here if we go through
trades now movie the night may be scary because
queen b1 check and maybe like this pawn could
be a little weak ourselves here so you got to
be careful but uh white's playing black's
playing pretty good black's playing a pretty
good game he's not been crushed by hikaru
izar azerbaijan azer bai shan thank you
because i always get that wrong i literally
always get it wrong and these are by chan
appreciate it we in here that's right we can hear
gizmeister can you have two i actually saw this
i just didn't think he would actually play this i
thought i thought he would find something better
but can you have two didn't make sense here but
now yeah this is annoying so i guess maybe it
was a good move but now this is annoying here and
we are going for trades now we can remove it the
queen doesn't have access here anymore that check
is very scary oh my goodness i gotta go king e2
and king d1 kg1 drops a knight king f1 you jumping
off the dpm basically i mean this feels like this
knight is game over but he went forward anyway
knight to g3 says that after knight to g3 and i
go king to g1 find a move big fella that's what he
says find a move i am hikaru nakamura and he stood
up and flexed real hard night yeah king g1 and
moved out of the way king f1 king g1 knight here
pushing e4 put it keeping the clock on him right
now keeping the clock on him he has one second
increment he's living off the increment knight to
d5 should win or close close and sacrifice on d4
he plays rick d1 instead because that was a check
now we could sack it anyway he says no sacking
i don't need to sack it i'm just going to
put the queen on f2 knight takes f3 is a pawn
he missed it no it's not queen takes f3 actually
knight g4 e5 now queen h4 same intention queen d8
knight h6 is there any win is there a win anywhere
anywhere nope nothing yet so he just takes it look
at this man surviving off this increment surviving
off the increment right now this is amazing
surviving could you cover gm vincent keimer
later yes we would love to thanks again for
listening i've increased my rating 400 points
pushing 1700 let's go quantum knights let's go
quantum knights with the big boy rating getting up
there now kicaro is actually lower on time too but
uh he is definitely he's he car was not living
off the increment i mean this is where he thrives
in this time control here guys rook to e3 knight
check move the king up not to get forked with the
knight here we go knight to e3 maybe knight to d5
is an attention takes takes maybe rookie 5 there
it is hitting g5 guys idea maybe even to play work
at 5. take on g5 the knights hanging knight d5 is
coming knight t5 is coming here it is check maybe
take on b6 this is definitely winning for white
now definitely winning for white now oh that's
a wrap start a new game he finds it time trouble
gets us all and hikaru nakamura does it again or
what else did you think he was gonna do what else
this is what this man does the carbon nakamura in
first place there's a lot of threes to be honest
actually there's actually um i can't actually
count all of them but there are there's a good
number of threes guys good number of threes three
and oh that's not a move says omni that's right
yep good number three's here let's
move on to another game though
um is vincent still playing are
we able to catch vincent keimer
if we see him we will check him out lawrence trent
is playing cool too easy says quantum knights too
easy this is interesting oh he dropped his rook
oh my goodness that hurts yikes just dropped
the whole thing it's gone it's gone hikaru
is not a human being you know he's half man
and then half blank and the blank is like
whatever you feel that with whatever you feel that
let's go over to uh oh last game last game
here should be ending in a few seconds here
and looks like a draw this would definitely be a
draw king h5 is a draw b4 yeah b4 is a draw too
either he's going to take it or i'm good he's
going to let me queen or whatever right there's
draw guys that's round number three nice job
nice job these guys are going at it going at it
we'll wait for round three here guys and
it started oh this is a big game right
here guys pay attention to this i mean we
won't leave this game at all alexis sheroff
sure i've got they there's variations named
after shiroff okay so alexis sheroff versus
hikaru nakamura this is a sight to see so don't
take your eyes off the screen if you don't know
alexis share off you can just google him to be
honest and you'll find a lot of fun stuff actually
um yeah went to uh it had some lessons in like
was the same place from tao basically they're
from the same place and stuff like that
it's like awesome shirt off nakamura bro
let's go okay but first off we have this roy lopez
but then it's a finchetto defense and i am not
familiar i mean after i left i played a scotch
gambit now and like the vienna sometimes but
um i'm usually always uh like i'm when i played
the roy lopez i never played the bishop g7 and
i've never faced it so this is a world i am not
familiar with with black but you know knocking
nakamura been finchetto in like every every game
with black he's been finchetto in that bishop
every game every single game he's been like
that okay let's move this back over here
amazing right yep so let if we look at the uh
the dynamicism of the game what's really going on
right now first off anytime you assess a position
guys i want you to really pay attention to this
anytime you come into a position you start with
the pawns just to assess to see what's going on
are the pawns the same do they have the same
amount what is it what is it right so six
pawns to six pawns except white has an isolated
pawn so that's a big difference and as you see
hikaru already recognizes that and the square
in front of the pawn is always just the most
important square especially when you're dealing
with an isolated pawn so you blockade the square
you trade the pieces to defend it maybe the queen
not this one because that would bring this pawn
closer to defend so that would be no good so you
want to make trades here h6 is probably incoming
something like maybe queen d6 and rook d8 but
we're going to bully this pawn and if we win
this pawn the game could be virtually over and
we have a target for the rest of the game so
this is really easy for um for hikaru to play
because he is playing when i see the pawn now
if i am playing with the isolated pawn as white
here the problem is or the problem is the isolated
pawn the second thing is i actually have to play
dynamically with shiroff has no problem playing
dynamically he has a g4 variation in almost
every every opening the shirt off g4 you know
he always likes to launch g4 so with that being
said we know sheriff is going to come up with
something here and try to limit the trades that
he makes because he'd know he has an isolated pawn
good content thanks nicolus nikolas you turned me
on to the scotch gambit and i finished people in
five moves see hey man look you know we don't
like to brag but we do know our scotch gambino
how long do these tournaments last 11
rounds we're in round uh four right now
run four right now 11 rounds three
minutes one second increment guys
last move was rook a to c1 and queen to d6 as
you see we said we were going to do this anyway
and probably maybe moving the rook at the f rook
now this knight on e5 is a monster here so he's
actually not only you know doing that but he's
freeing up the knight to be able to take on e4 or
play something like knight to d7 rook to d1 would
almost be a blunder almost of course bishop g4
is looming looming it's not there because knight
takes g4 but there is some variations that could
happen where uh that could be available knight to
d7 seems like that's incoming here sheriff was up
more time here but now of course when you're
playing cardboard hikaru was not down on time
like at all now he's uh he's um down a little bit
on time it's kind of going back and forth here but
he has a a super tough opponent used to study with
tao from the same city as tao guys so this man is
amazing so eval bar actually let me turn
that on for you but i have to fix something
there we go it should work
there we go there's the eval bar gotcha
what's up rockas what's going on man
you always get caught with the bishop takes f7
queen h5 trick that does happen yeah there's the
eval bar for you neil fire on a boar versus
eyes on the ceiling right i mean right come
on now come on eval bar saying it's about equal
here let's actually see what's really going on
knight to b4 hey carl what's he
threatening he's really threatening a2
i know he thought a3 oh that lost on the spot
i mean on the spot that was a terrible move
engine's like get out of here trust game with
the six months let's go yeah i guess that was
it queen takes d4 start a new game you dropping
everything knight takes c6 that's not a move
knight takes c6 and we can start a new one
big fella not today yeah we know you shiroff
but not today basically is what not gorf is saying
nakamura is saying because this is uh this is over
resignation gg yikes yeah i think he just
blundered here can't you just play a3
what was he scared of oh i guess just taking
anyway that was a strong move bro the car
route is just another level bro man this
was nice it was fun to see this takes takes
bishop h4 stepping out of the way of f6 and the
knight before dang that pawn was hanging and
you see what happened he lost the the moment
after the isolated pawn was captured he lost
guys okay it's very very important right what
did we talk about the entire game was this pawn
and as soon as he took it the game was over
be aware and play it pay attention to the
isolated pawns we have liam lay i always just
say that because like liam lay q or q liam lay
but liam lee william lee very strong player
of course as we know guys he is from vietnam
but this position doesn't look that strong
i'm just going to be honest just staring at
it just like quick glance look over look away
like what happened there's two knights here
the king side is absolutely ridiculous there's so
many holes over here one two three four pieces are
close by the king in attacking situations you
will count the pawn as a piece even though it's
a pawn but usually you just call it a pawn but
of course in attacking situations you will count
this as one of the pieces you used to attack here
pawn takes knight uh this is intro oh yikes okay
okay it feels like it feels like everything
is hanging it feels like he's getting mated
it says mate in three and just says mate in
three oh here it is kg1 knight h3 oh my goodness
oh whoa don't even do it to him like that
why do you do it to him like that wow amazing
amazing recommendations best way to learn theory
um you can start with watching grand master games
in games that you like or openings that you like
even classics and then you can start finding
opening books use chess.com of course they have
the openings tool the opening explorer which helps
you a lot so you do want to use the chest.com
tool on that highly recommend it chess warrior
yeah white's just crushing right
he's oh he's playing on because this is kind
of like one of those i'm mad kind of games
because the gm is losing he's and he's like
up 100 points basically he's just kind of
mad here so he's just gonna play on it does
happen though it does happen knight takes g2
yes this is game over guys but he's just gonna
play on now queening if you queen rick takes g2
if you queen his rook takes g2 he was
trying to get him in a stalemate trick
that would have been amazing c360 for the kill
king what's up matt dub welcome thank you so much
how is this how are you making this so hard
for yourself okay i was like why is this so
hard why is he like why is this so difficult for
him right now there it is okay you figured it out
we figured it out there still got more games
left let's check out this next one parked in
easy one guys easy one very easy of course for
people that don't know how to you know mate with
king and queen just pay attention here just pay
attention never thought queen's gamut series would
force me to play chess let's go yeah you playing
chess now excellent if you are from the queen's
gambit series much love to you make sure you
get on chess.com upgrade your account to premium
and start using the tools and get right get right
okay that game's over fair play fair chess play
what is his name fair chess on
youtube okay fair chess on youtube
this is a hard one oh queen x you could have won
queen h6 but i guess oh he's just trying to snap
the pawns because they're annoying right snap all
the pawns first i would just take the pawn take
the punt there we go take the pawn and don't worry
about now now you can go to work on the technique
now it even have the extra pawn that even helps
even more usually king and queen versus king rick
it is a win it's just a lot of technicalities to
it but here now it's a lot easier because you have
this extra pawn so i mean everything wins here he
has a check uh he could have taken queen takes h7
king g7 doesn't matter there's a queen gg
g g games over there let's go over here to
this one games are ending guys games are ending
games are ending that all of them
let's just see
let's see guys
cool all the games are finished excellent all
right guys so let's take a look at cool real
quick at the standings this is what the sandies
look like after four rounds we got a few fours
some threes and things like that guys but we
will return very soon guys we're gonna take a
quick break fair play check guys and we'll see
you guys very soon don't go anywhere don't go
anywhere this is title tuesday double the prizes
guys and we'll see you as soon as we get back
so
and we're back guys and we are we are
back let's go let's go okay round five
has started let's get right into the games
okay here we go ikaro versus angry twin this
is international master out of russia
nice russia they're born actually uh
2100 over there or always born like
2100 over there where is actually
kind of weird different link
there it is actually found it here we go guys it's
like what here we go angry twins right here what's
the time three minutes one second increment guys
yeah they like boring 2100 over there right so
all right let's actually uh go back though and see
what happens so we got back here and what what was
this opening oh semi semi slob okay send me some
look at that g4 aggressive using shiroff's tactics
in a way g4 okay so we got this far into the
game and honestly oh i like this attack by white
knight g5 my my goodness like this man hikaru
is a monster look at this pawn takes now you're
in trouble in a way bishop v4 would be beautiful
we would love to do this but of course we can't
because of the pawn here but this was mate so
he had to cover mate so he played queen to g6
also his queen was hanging so queen g6 was
forced we would love to play bishop before
of course once again he might be thinking about
this move and actually sacrificing the pawn
maybe sacrificing too much maybe a
little bit too much but we will see
in place queen a4 just gets out of the
way queen takes b4 is a possibility
you have to ask is he really going to take this
pawn though the king is here it's very weak on c1
and the rook to c8 does happen at the right
moment he could be in a lot of trouble guys
a lot of trouble could it could happen for him
a lot of trouble b5 happened pawn takes
yeah again this c file is very weak
but he has a weak h file so it's kind of the same
yo thanks williams appreciate you thank you thank
you okay cool so what's going on queen to d3
so he dig it out of the way a little bit
king b1 is going to be played eventually
let's see if we have anything in the meantime
can we get f4 to work he plays f3 instead bishop
h4 is the intention with some trouble after
bishop e7 very very careful with your life here
very very careful
cool got it perfect blue background
you like the blue thanks banana
all right so white's definitely doing great
here as we as you see the bishops are going
to swipe this board the question is how do we get
in here so maybe like rick g1 reason for that i
want to play rook h6 and double but as soon as
you move the rook he's just gonna take this one
so you may need to move this one first so you
can be allowed to play something like work h6
maybe it's not called for though it might be too
aggressive that's my problem my problem which is
a good problem to have is that you know i'm too
aggressive sometimes my favorite player is tal
i have the game my life and games of town
so i'm always thinking about how does how
would he play it he would destroy you like this
time and experience to know the positions you
can do that in but uh yeah definitely trying
to get something to work on this h file here
now we have to trade and like it gets kind
of annoying but this will be a technical win
here and and he car was very good at the technical
wins where you have to really kind of grind it out
use the advantage and even abandon what you
thought was the best he abandoned what he what
looked great right and now he's just a completely
different system moves the bishop around me carl
is an expert or mastery wizard a grand mastery
everything else at this technique here just
being able to switch and do something else and
and doing the unexpected very very strong very
very strong chess oh thank you appreciate that jj
the ultra appreciate it man i'm loving it myself
loving it there was a check here bishop before
looking good queen c5 i think's a little bit
better maybe get the queen a little bit
more active because it's not doing much
over here so he goes back instead says kick
the bishop maybe e4 actually that hangs upon
so he plays rick c5 keeping the threats up it's
always good to keep threats alive guys always good
to keep the threats up rick c5 not only did my
rook get to a better square it hit the bishop and
hit it with tempo give my king in a better square
knight a4 was a fork knight to d7 now we probably
should back up come back home to civilization and
what should we do now since icaru may be pushing
maybe that's a strong maybe but maybe pushing
just to see what happens he boozes bishop to a5
it's a very surprising move very surprising move
but you get tons of those from hikaru like i don't
even know what this move ever does at all i have
no idea basically if i guess it blocks this it's
uh def it's just a weird move bishop a5 bishop b4
bishop c5 this is more solid here more attention
to it rick to c3 hitting the bishop get out of the
way maybe bishop h1 yeah he did that too bishop h1
no trades keep the clock running on him knight
takes b3 was an option dang angry twin is strong
like he just keeps swinging at hikaru bishop f8
there it is game's over game's over he got caught
with one you know those guys this boxing he's
swinging at him and swinging man this guy's good
and then he he got caught by his chin with an
uppercut and that's it that's it this should be
over in a few check bring the rookie in now there
is no checks for black besides knight takes b3
and queenie two which uh he might have a perpetual
huh yeah i understand hikaru i do one now you can
the combos are too much hit him with the check
here hit him with the check here i guess he had
a perpetual he had a perpetual knight takes
b3 and queen e2 was was very weird if you
step around it he would check you if you took the
knight he was going to check you many many times
many many times
okay
nice jobby karu nice combo in
the end see that one more time
yeah didn't work beautiful absolutely beautiful
chest there carl was putting on a display here
they're just coming in and i'm just trying
to win like that's it i'm just coming in and
i'm just trying to win like another day in the
office boys nothing in the office jesse carver
another day in the office
five out of five jostling was playing really
good too josslyn was playing really good chess
yeah hikaru and uh joshua
josslyn's in first place too
josslyn's like first first i have tie breaks first
11 out of uh like 11 is this tie
break like wow eleven point to me
yeah at this level one blunder will wreck
your entire game john guy think about this
one inaccuracy in the opening not even losing
upon like you know just wrong move order in
the opening you know it's over oh that that
theory was 1970s they don't do that anymore
you know it's that kind of level kingy one white's
winning here oh can you just oh yeah yeah that
just works that works i was thinking rook takes
first for some reason but bishop c6 just works
his pinned take it and then we're queening anyway
gg brandon jacobson's strong too i see him play
a lot last game here oh we have a a weird well
actually there's two pawns on the board so this
should be way easier for black to win if these
pawns if all three pawns were gone guys this would
be very hard for black to win bishop versus rook
bishop and rick king versus king rook one of the
hardest ones now of course you can see the person
with the bishop and rook checkmate but there's a
certain certain sequence of moves to have have
that have to happen and it does it's not easy
it's not easy a lot of uh triangulation and like
uh maneuvering and then zoo swing and then like
rook here but then you gotta stop here but then
you gotta check them here and then you gotta come
back to the fourth ring then go up here then back
to the seventh ring and then move the bishop it's
insane it's insane it's endeavor rescues in-game
manual which is uh really really ridiculous
black won that one yeah this one was easier with
the pawn too and of course no work on the board
and that's the end of round five guys after five
rounds let's see who's sitting up at the top here
actually itari zaga the terry zaga from venezuela
actually sitting at top let's take a look at their
game so let's see who's at the top here brandon
jacobson and hikar was right at the top once again
have you been up to date have oh you have to
be up to date with theory opening theory is
very important to know yeah brandon jacobson
is i am strong yeah he's uh he's really strong
really strong oh we have a night or shout
out to all the night or fans out there but
actually no this is some type of dragon like i
see g6 here i saw a6 and d6 immediately thought
then he has an early a6 though in this which
is uh different you know guys i think carlo has
played the bishop on g7 every single game with
black if you guys notice every single game with
black he's put the bishop on g7 if you know that
that cuts down a lot of study time even for me
when i was playing a hyper-accelerated dragon with
black i would put the bishop on g7 but now with um
d4 i'm able to play king's indian defense which
is still bishop on g7 what is the best book for
middle game that's a great question honestly
and it's not many books out there on middle
game but one of the strongest and the hardest
ones is panchenko's mastering middle games
that's a mastering chess middle
game so that was not a easy
it was not easy at all so other than that one i
don't really know any like it's hard to find those
but here i think black has a really strong
position he didn't castle notice guys your
king your king doesn't have to castle every single
game a lot of people think that you have to castle
every single game but that is not true that is not
true at all you your king actually sometimes is
safer here because of king side attacks and also
you see what he did here he shut down all counter
play for the g pawn if you're playing white
here what's your what do you usually do right
you're gonna push the pawns you're gonna play
the bishop over here and you're gonna try to mate
but he cut that off and the kings here in the
center looking kind of safe maybe king to d7
in some cases that looks crazy though king d7
might be too much to try to activate the rooks but
we'll see what he does thank you so
much no problem what's up sith what's up
977 here's a very close pawn structure to protect
the king correct correct and now we do trades
trades definitely will help black in any sicilian
guys not any but most sicilians if you think about
this trades will help black so if you're playing
and you don't know what you're doing maybe you
got a cramped position and cramped positions even
outside the sicilian trading is generally the rule
here though uh it dude it does help it does help
to make some trades here for black the bishops
even get to open up towards the king a little bit
even as queen b8 move it's this very sneaky move
because it also threatens stuff like b4 maybe
a5 a4 first to anchor this pawn at a3 so when
we break with b4 he can't push past me if we play
b4 a4 is kind of annoying so he actually moves his
queen back to c7 instead though keeping pressure
here on c2 the idea is 95 knight c4 type stuff
bishop back to e6 weird
that's funny that's funny gory
is my guy too corey's awesome c3
i still got knight e5 bishop b3
first okay then knight a5 there it is
very interesting though you never believe you're
crying you guys are crazy 95 knight to c4 looks
really good bishop c42 which one's better
is the question bishop c4 allows knight b3
and if you take it then i have knight c4 anyway
he pre-moved that that was on pre-move he knew
he was going to play e5 and then back to bishop
up now knight to b3 and knight c4 look at the
domination here bishop f5 is coming man bishops
on g7 like what happened here only a few moves
and now black is just feels like
dominating now bishop f5 seems scary
luckily this bishop covers here because bishop f5
would end it all followed by queen to c4 it will
be queen c4 bishop f5 and knight b3 as the combo
but the bishop keeps this from from happening so
at least he's okay but you see how he's trying
to do it anyway he's trying to get it in this way
and the knight to b3 same thing
3200 too strong for this field yeah
he got a few that could hang with him
a lot like really hard you know we got a
few but very few what if you just check now
b3 man that sucks to play b3 but it might be
okay might be okay or actually you just move
the king back no the knight check
and then takes and then bishop e6
check here white's just winning now doesn't it i
think it still works no he has bishop d1 bishop h6
very strong that's a piece oh my goodness look
at the disconnection this is gross like oh my
like this is a family channel you know ikaru
man this is ridiculous bishop takes d2 anyway
okay we gotta show this guys bishop takes d2
right bishop takes d2 this was gross take my
rook i don't care your queen's hanging and your
king's hanging your king is hanging so let's move
the queen out of the way and then check king here
you can't go anywhere look at the domination of
all the pieces here beautiful harmony here you can
do literally anything but this one's mate though
this one's made beautiful yeah the king
was hanging i mean yeah queen's hanging
but your king's definitely hanging over here
jeez man big boy chest from the big fella
okay rick b2 he's getting off the diagonal
but you could also take it too maybe he wants
to double take him double could be a possibility
double pawns aren't that good how did he get here
usually you have double pawns if you lose one of
your knights like that but somehow it was a bishop
for him it seems like that's kind of that's very
weird it's a very weird position like how did you
get this to happen without losing a knight it's
kind of different rick p6 knight takes e5 yeah
this doesn't look good too too good for white i
don't like this too much three six three four five
i'm like down the pawn and i have double pawns
here doesn't feel good great peace harmony killer
diagonals i know that was amazing that was
absolutely amazing that was sharp for white
yes he had a series of moves just to stay alive
correct have you studied tarash the game let me
study to wrest the game of chess at all no i've
never actually heard of that book but i do know um
tarash the player and also the opening is dynamic
very dynamic and underrated very underrated
fish takes d5 get a pawn at least oh that's
nice though that's nice that's even better
that's even better check get out
the way i'm good white's fighting
he is fighting living off the increment
here and fighting his way back to something
be careful don't get made it just probably walk
the king up honestly as weird as this is oh
engine didn't like that at all it must have been
something like f6 lock him in like we saw daniel
naredichki do yesterday to uh timor that was nasty
that lock in that mate was gross takes rook b7
living off the increment here and now actually
what's his name gwenplan going plane with the
black pieces here is now right same living
off the increment it's almost made luckily
this is losing some oh my goodness hit that man
with the move wow that's mate that is checkmate
check the screen check the screen look
at look at the screen right now it's made
it's made i didn't think that was made at
all i thought he just was going to check him
wow did you see that yo that
hurts that definitely hurt
that was a pretty mate i mean you don't
see that often you don't see that often
family stream you already know come on
now made on the middle of the board i mean
what a mate that was great
tang bruh that's sweet sweet guys that
was amazing that was absolutely amazing
let's check out this gm here
living off the increment this is a draw guys dead
draw here and a draw was offered but declined
decline says no i'm about to flag you
i know you get one second every move
but i'm still gonna flag you is what he says
here ball and james let's go let's go
what's up ob man this is a draw guys
this is a draw this is probably going to
be the last game of this round let's see
if any other players are uh yeah it's one of the
last games now okay they took a draw there it is
there it is okay cool they didn't keep us here to
tomorrow we're good oh this is an interesting one
surprisingly you see how the eval bar says is
equal here you would think that the two ricks
would be better but there's nothing else on the
board but these pieces so that makes a difference
um that's a check step out of the way
another check oh knight b3 missing 83.
oh he's in trouble oh my goodness he lost
no he didn't okay he found a move at least
this is a cool game to learn something from guys
because i don't know what's going to happen
here he wants to play knight f3 king f4
i honestly don't know what's going to happen oh
50 move rule okay thanks chess.com appreciate it
that's funny a 50 move rule okay here we go hikaru
and joss bum this is a big boy game right here
this is a very very strong game guys
hey carl versus josslyn both of these
players of course are legends he carried more
than josslyn but that's josephine is known
and if you don't know today you're going to
know he has six games same amount is he karu
same amount he has to play all the same
players he carved but basically has to play
but is he they're not hikaru
right so let's see what happens
let's see what happens here so this
opening choice was the bishop's opening
if a favorite of near disney's as well
a3 and blitz games knight to g3 probably
i don't really know the theory
behind this this is some kind of uh
it means feels like a roy feels like
a roy but it's really not a roy though
again it's the bishop's opening
who is young karthia kyan murali
queenie two's on the board i'm just not a big
fan of this bishop's opening kind of setup here
i would rather have my bishop either on a2 or
g2 more in the king's indian attack fashion
if we're gonna have this pawn set up like
this this is usually what you'll
have in the king's indian attack
takes takes and you know we have to play we
have to it's a game castle we're out of the
way here maybe h3 bishop g4 is quite annoying
there it is h3 and h6 was doing the same bishop
to e6 it actually was stopping knight g5
because that's annoying so bishop v6 he's
not really going to take on b3 and give up the
bishop here because it is a slight advantage
bishop to d2 not only does it connect my
rooks but bishop to c3 is an option to hit the
e5 pawn there it is immediately bishop
d6 would have probably answered with here
and maybe sacrificing some material knight
to d7 defending e5 very beautiful move here
getting out of the range knight to d3 f6
probably now to defend maybe followed by b4
plays bishop d6 instead interesting move
does not want to play f6 so he says knight h4
i'm gonna take over this f5 square might try to
bring another knight around there too works at d1
93 looks bad by the way yeah now and now it's
looking pretty good c5 very strong move i mean
these pawns are extreme extremely annoying here
that's why i actually whipped out b4 before
because i was like yeah b4 b4 wow b4 b4 yeah but
uh i was going to play b4 before but it was um
it was this because of this like this is
annoying you have to back everything up now
not the easiest knight c5 c5 b4 there it is
takes takes black's the one pressing a little bit
pip and chuck what's up man how are
you welcome to the stream let's go
can you look at the standings somewhere standings
are actually right under me guys right under me
if you want to look at them actually yourself
too as well you can actually go into live chess
click on tournaments into live when you're
live chess and click on the in progress tab
actually there's a link right there
appreciate that from max milneck there he is
in the chat you can click that link right
there buddy queen of three knight f5
these pawns got a little bit too far than what
they were supposed to so black has more space
than white does this knight is gross but again
remember we talked about getting the knight to f5
so maybe that's the route we might take at this
point but if this knight moves and rig a2 happens
and then you have problems here on the back rank
and past pawns that are a little bit further than
they should be so if we play 92 rook a2 could
be immediate maybe bishop c1 in that area though
because this bishop is not doing anything
anymore so maybe 92 rook a 2 and bishop c1
still playing knight f5 in some cases even though
this pawn's here there it is 92 if rook to a2 we
play bishop c1 and defend it bishop h4
hitting the knight that's a great move
that was a really good move g3 yeah this is
how you know it's not that easy for him anymore
bishop takes h4 pawn takes and h5 we could use
this h-pawn as a lure but this pawn's hanging
i told you guys joseph came to play you know
jasmine got the same amount of points as hikaru
and you know he's pressuring hikaru here this
pawn's hanging these pawns are doing real good
if you look at the engine the engine is like you
know the car was crushed here basically but of
course you are we're not playing engines here
you know this there's going to be human moves
and you know this three this minus three could
go to equal very quickly you'd be surprised
you you would be surprised here so good evening
humans what's up what's up jackie the alien what's
up man e4 is hanging it was it was i can't see
really enjoyed commentary thank you so much kenra
yep i hope you have a great time there in the us
chess qualifiers we have off day today night to
see one the knights on c1 now rook a1 just doing
a thing back here i mean look at all of white's
pieces right hikaru is not that happy in this
position all the pieces are backtracking here
we don't have the real attack but we can maybe
see something like bishop e3 queen h6 king h2
rook h1 and king g1 sounds ridiculous but it's
a plan and a bad plan is better than no plan at
all we have seven out of seven we'll have some oh
somebody got seven out of seven we've got seven
six and a half i see a six and a half
from fair chess six and a half so far
okay dude was joshua you know what i forgot
his name but i always know him for my job
like that's how i know him joshua and i was
saying this guy still is so strong like he's so
strong oh here he is jose eduardo martinez there
he is yeah he's really strong he's always at the
top if you look at the binoculars when you're
playing live chess and you're watching games
he's like always at the top so from watching
games i will see him play like every day bishop c4
hitting e2 queen to e1 defending again this is
not the position white wanted here and as he's
starting to feel it bishop to c5 almost seemed
like detrimental but we could block with the
bishop or the knight as he does so bishop c5
step out of the way king of g2 and you see this
pawn is trying to queen here the knights are
doing a great job controlling what we can do
but the only thing we're doing right now is
defending this is very bad in hikaru's situation
reason being is because this is three minutes
one second increment and they are getting down
on time good thing for hikaru is he's uptime he's
up time so maybe he can swindle something here
hopefully carl saves this yeah he could if he
fails to do this josslyn should be winning you
see that the engine just shifted hard there
very hard shift rick d1 was not the move
rookie d1 was not to move but bishop takes e3 and
now it's about even again and even though it's
minus one human evaluation when you're looking
at the eval bar and you're looking at humans play
you know this is not lost you see how it went
back to zeros right it's like oh minus four zeros
minus this is big boy chess right queen
here hitting queen takes f6 queen g7
and he's running out of time yeah this might
be a uh this might be a swindle this could be
a swindle here i feel i feel the pressure hikaru
was putting on him right now there it is some that
didn't work knight f6 check anyway if knight
takes queen takes so he moves out of the way
just take on e4 white is now winning this game
can you believe that swindle didn't we call it
right he's gonna swindle him somehow and if you
look at the clock here he's down losing the rook
right afterwards that hurts that one hurt that
one hurt probably knock everything off the table
at that moment anything in front of me
is now on the floor after that game yikes
yep that hurts it definitely hurts but you can't
make a mistake on that even like when you you know
you ever played the computer back in the day or
like you know it's just playing botsonchest.com
and you're like i was winning i was winning and
they just crush you after you make a mistake
the small mistakes too right small mistakes not
something that the human eye that's why he's half
something i don't know the other half the human
eye won't see all right and that was a win by
prague look at prague playing guys bragg's playing
i mean they bring we bring out everyone like title
tuesday goes down everybody's here darrow look
on his day off on his day off you know playing
playing today bishop c4 king e5 no fork right it
was no fork did you take c6 i wonder if you could
win this to be honest engine doesn't think so but
like you know i'm playing a human here king d6 was
probably a little bit better especially in his
time issue uh he would have took a bishop though
see what he gets let's see what
he gets he car was the beast yes
i know i know i know it's always
a pleasure to watch ekaro play
can he do anything about that
wow i have no like not that
i've never seen this but this is
this is pretty cool to watch actually like can
he actually do something about this this move
doesn't seem like he can right look at him just
moving back and forth like this hey blunder yeah
i'm trying i'm trying to figure out there's no
tricks i was trying to work something out but
there's no tricks i was trying to get h5
to work or like sacking and then playing h5
but it actually just doesn't work
what are you doing what is this
what are we coming to watch today are
you serious this got to be the last game
this has got to be the last game yeah it's two
games left and guess who one of the games are
i wonder does this oh yeah all he has to do
that was nice that was nice look at him play
back and forth if anyone steps out it's like
they call these mind squares wow how do you oh
my goodness oh my goodness this is a draw by
the way it's a draw no matter what it's a draw
but it's just kind of funny how that happened
bro what you're holding everybody up right
now yo and everybody everybody just staring
at him everybody stare at him real quick you
know just stare at him through the screen
what are you doing here why are you thinking
installing come on max come on there we go
oh my goodness somebody get you man that was
round seven round seven let's take a look
at the standings before the round starts here
round seven and around eight who do you think
of course who else do you think would
be at the top up here right look at this
look at this round seven guys round
seven has started let's take a look
at the games ikaru and bogdan uh he's playing
this again yo guys if you study nakamura's games
and this helps a lot to cut down
on study time because like for me
i play the kings indian defense against
everything except e4 everything has said before
so if you're playing d4 c4 b3 knight f3 a4 h4 i'm
going to play knight f6 and g6 and most likely
g7 in some king city and fashion and if you
notice every single game played with black here
he has done this setup g6 and bishop g7 and he
does other stuff but g6 and bishop g7 every single
time it's very easy to study that way when you
just figure out kind of what player you are i know
i love tactics and i love having a bishop on g7 so
it's nice to watch him play nice to watch him play
round eight guys round eight is here when you
see the winner this is dallas j herr always wins
jackie the alien all right well let's go back
i want to i'm going to see a few moves here
knight takes 95 knight c3 queen f3 queen of six
i don't like trading queens early i am not a fan
if i don't have to if there's other things that i
can do and then i'll do those as long as it's not
losing right but i'm not trying to trade queens
immediately bishop g5 that does hang a knight
but queen takes f7 was made so he actually just
captures just so you know guys knight takes f3 now
it's just boring it's boring this is boring and
nakamura has two bishops swiping the board so it's
not too boring for him but for white i'm like i
didn't i didn't like this too much maybe ricky won
thanks 201 steve's appreciate it 97
i feel like you could do this you you
probably should know this is ikaru
the reason being bishop takes king takes rook
takes i get two pawns i get a third and i'm
hitting the knight so but that shouldn't be enough
i mean especially playing cardboard don't jump off
the dpn like don't even do that to yourself
so let's not do that you just play rookie one
defending the pawn the question is what does
he do with his king castle is not allowed
d6 might be e5 might be because bishop takes f3
is a nice little in-between move that could work
but uh i wonder like this d6 is there
problems is he scared of this move
i don't know
yeah typically kings always
hide in that castle yes
well hey carl's thinking though this
is a first he doesn't think that much
right doesn't think that much so when he's
thinking that's a problem you know hey carlos
starts thinking you might be in trouble you
might be in some trouble let's put standings up
some sevens yeah just two sevens there's d6 yeah
look at this nice grip on e5 a bind here knight
to d5 looks pretty good if knight takes pawn takes
and we will expose the king here but the king can
move maybe f7 or d7 and we do remove this knight
this is a possibility to capture this probably
not the best though especially after the check
knight d4 follows with knight e6 being annoying
so maybe not capturing but in areas
he goes forward anyway it takes
and knight d496 is a possibility but the
pawn hangs in between that so if we go
knight before you block the connection of
the rick to the pawn so this actually hangs
leading to another pawn that's actually
hanging and taking away e6 for the night
so yeah this is pretty good because this is a
target so you have to play c4 you need to free
up this root so c4 is probably has to be played
that's probably the best move and then you can
anchor the pawn so you can try to get the knight
in here he's thinking a little bit too much a
little bit too much here even though it's 3-1 you
don't have many moves though actually these are
like weird moves you could make them but there's
94 anyway so bishop takes here maybe knight takes
b5 maybe he's saying he can justify it i don't
think that's right i don't think that works
counseling sensibilities change at all when you
consider castling before the finch had a bishop
do castle extensibilities change
at all when you consider castling
behind the finchetto bishop uh you well generally
speaking casting behind the fin shadow bishop is
a good way to you know have king safety
and also be able to attack to as well so
if you canceled over here this bishop is still
strong but if you give it up then you do have
holes around the king so you have to be careful
it's a you know a little bit of both honestly
good question nice how you mr protector
yeah petey hemps thank you so much for that
whoa what happened wait wait wait wait something
that boy shot up white was winning all right lots
oh rookie seven oh my goodness he blunted rookie
seven he covered blunder rook e7 missed it
and then it would name me in this line right
here hey carl's actually down a piece right now
rookie 7 was game over that was lights out not
gonna drop the whole piece whole thing go oh thank
god naka craig angry commentary appreciate
it no problem show jimbo thank you so much
bro welcome to the stream carl's good at blitz
he's good at everything he's good at everything
question is how and do we get this knight is it
this way 23 seconds you need to move a little bit
faster here i mean i guess this it's easier said
than done you are you're up a piece here you feel
like you're winning you're playing in car rule
right so i guess he's going to give it back here
knight e8s oh he's just getting
this pawn makes sense bishop d4
h4 that was gross that was gross like you had the
other way to go and now you have
to like give him this counter play
h3g4 h3g4 okay
they should d8 oh yeah he's missing all the
moves like bishop missing everything but
his nine seconds and this three minutes one
second increment here and carl lives right
here i mean this is and hicario has a lot of
time to be honest in his eyes now this hanging
king goes back draws looking in game very dry it's
looking in game here but he cargo doesn't draw
nothing he doesn't care about a draw that's not
what he does three minutes one second increment
he's going he's gonna push i guarantee you i
guarantee you hikaru's not gonna take a draw
i can guarantee that to you and even with
29.85 even though the man's rating is 29.85
hit carl loses like 10 points he lose 10 points
if he if he draws his game he lose like six points
all right which is still a win it's like
a oh man that's a nice win six points cool
drew the game interesting he's sacrificed here
yeah he couldn't figure it out they couldn't
figure it out so this is going to end in the draw
and not a draw because he wanted
one more because it was like forced
yeah he didn't want to draw at all look at that
you see what he did yeah i got a draw with a 2900
i lost five points right that never comes out of
your mouth unless you're in carburetor nakamura
here's uh oh they both well seven and seven
seven and a half they were both the top dogs
so they both got seven and a half there see if
any games are left guys yeah we got some games
left mom and me i know right we have prague here
prague and fair chess youtube pranks playing white
playing black draw another draw good
game guys good game great chess here
white is mating there it is easy
mate walk in somebody get mated
all games should be ending soon this
one's a draw shuffle back and forth wow
you wanted to win that bad you ever been there
before you know that's that's a tough one
that doesn't work you just take it and
defend upon so oh yes it's still a draw
i guess it's the draw technically
you never have to move the king
yeah technically that's still a draw are you able
to push this oh that was sweet hold up hold up
now you can't get to him he can't get to him
there's not enough moves yeah there's no entry
squares like there's no way to enter anything
that's why it's still a draw java doing well
yep there we go there's a draw there he sacrificed
spawn still got to draw a strong game there whoa
oh man he flagged you rarely see that you rarely
see flagging in three one three minute one second
increment that kind of sucks there there's made
on the back rank there it is make it very easy
here and this right here guys is the final game
and this is another draw another classic position
guys we talked about this before and there's
a stalemate and there it is still made it
still made it that's round eight let's take a look
at the standings really quickly really quickly
bogged in actually on tie breaks got a one like
literally just by one point on tie breaks so far
it's like crazy but as you see here seven and a
half seven and a half we got some sevens in here
and i mean these guys are pushing tight guys it's
gonna be awesome here but uh round nine is gonna
be starting soon guys so round that's gonna
be starting soon but we're gonna take a quick
break so don't go anywhere enjoy it guys good to
see you in the chat and we'll be back in a few
please please show us your sorcery once more
prefer maiden guys how many times do i have
to tell you it's not sorcery it's on juno the
mystical slab of divine enlightenment your king
holds the wealth of the land that you work so hard
to harvest that you get so little in return with
onjuno you can get more on your deposits i have
no idea what any of that means your king is greedy
he could let you earn more but he doesn't
believe you have a choice yeah we want
more coin we want more coins we want more coin
perfect i think you guys are starting to get it
yes it is here's the witch
oh i don't think they like me
not only do the big banks hoe is the only
interest you could build with your deposits
they also crash you with absurd fees that
net them billions of dollars every year
oh shut up you can't you don't know what
you're doing if you do this it'll spread
a curse across all the line my lord
she showed us the light she's a witch
as a digital banking platform on juno keeps its
costs low there are no hidden fees no minimum
bounce fees and no worries i don't respect what
you're saying because it's new and different
and it scares me and if you want to send your
money around the globe soon you'll be able to at
a great price with no hassle the world is flat
the world is flat right yes for sure which way
and who doesn't love getting cash
back on their favorite brands
i do love my cash back okay you're
a queen now oh wow thank you
our rain has just begun make the switch to anjuno
what's going on guys we're back we're back we're
back round nine has started let's go hikaru is in
the ring he's up in first place with bogdan who's
actually tied actually no bogdan has first off
tie breaks and carl is actually second but he has
the same amount of points with seven and a half
so let's actually pull the game up guys let's
get right into it here we go uh there it is
okay so here's the game that's what we got
so far his his signature stuff would be three
the usual right signature stuff there's a
standings right there so there's a queen
on c8 it's almost like he started like this in
960 fashion kind of weird kind of a weird setup
he moved the queen to c8 then he moved
the rick to d8 but i think he's prepping
guys for this d5 push if you see this like x right
here always be aware of the x-rays what they say
always be aware of the x-ray so richard d8 is on
the board as we have icaru thinking about this one
let's see well e4 actually fails tonight takes d4
so actually plays knight to c2 instead interesting
gets the knight out of the way now he can play
knight e4 and knight to e3 to take over the d5
square if he ever tries to play e6 and e6 actually
leaves a hole on d6 allowing knight b5 knight to
d6 95 good move just trading because i have less
space if you have less space you look for trades
and white has less space or black has
less space so he wanted to trade there
and he does he's he's successful in that attempt
now queen to b7 the queen has now can help
connect the rooks knight has to go somewhere
knight g4 loses the knight actually after h3
this pawn is actually defended so you have to go
back knight c6 rook be one on pre-move basically
defending the bishop some of the best players
in the world the best attacking players always
make sure the pieces are defended before doing
anything else and the pieces here is defended
the bishops nicely defended against any type of
attacks or anything that can happen in the future
pretty pretty different how many total players
are in a tournament we have a 515 players
how are some enemies higher rated than gm's uh
because they you know you just get stronger and
when you get stronger it shows in your game and
your rating so a lot of people are underrated
especially in this year you know people have
been studying not able to play in tournaments
it's going to be a lot of un underrated players
coming through so be careful what section you win
when you go play on your over to board
tournaments be careful on what section
you're playing in take every game serious because
you don't know what they did in the off time
queen to e2 e45 knight b 596 it white has a very
nice grip on the on everything i think this might
have to be played because e4 is a very strong
move this is very strong so maybe can you get
away with d5 takes yeah you could you could play
d5 the intention is just stopping the e4 square
from having any type of action because it has
a lot of action right now e4 can be very strong
followed by something like f5 or e5 if e4 and e5
you go knight e4 knight d6 and all the pieces just
get annoying there it is d5 is on the board he
pre-moved captures actually takes and now he's
taking over the e4 square that we wanted so bad
now rick to d1 attacking the pawn so either or
we would have been able to play e4 but we're going
to bully this pawn one or the other and he chose
well i'm just not going to give you the square
so you're going to have to bully my pawn
and that's what he's doing maybe queen f3 we could
see next to see if this works there it is queen f3
queen f3 cardigan title and there's
so many few live tournaments yeah
all the titles are based on classical
rating and norms that is right
that is right queens on f3 though queens on f3
this pawn is hanging you have a choice to make
do we play knight e4 but that just hangs
um yeah d4 i was about to say that and let
them just capture and then we capture this
pawn and our our bank we're banking on us to
to find some type of counter play around
around this pawn it's black if i'm playing
black here i need to figure out can i win
this pawn back because white's now up a pawn
isolated correct this isolated true true queen
true the true king with the q yeah it's definitely
uh isolated definitely i said it so that's that's
the plan we have to bully the isolated pawn like
we talked about earlier today too is like pile
the pieces on it try to control the square in
front of the pawn so moves like knight d6 and
knight f5 jump into mine he's actually giving
it back right now he gave it back right now oh
did he have to let's go back he might have had to
after a5 so does knight c2 do no good you in
trouble on ic2 apparently i guess he didn't
like knight c2 maybe b5 or something
so he had to give it back in the way
what up james do you ever play in t in title
tuesday i actually play entitled tuesday i
my best score was six points six points it was
six or six and a half which is nice we're all
psyched let's go eleven rounds you know let's go i
took some else to some big fellas but i did i took
down some big fellas as well so i had six out of
eleven it was pretty nice this was uh last year my
last title tuesday but i do like commentating them
and watching and just like when they're on it's
like awesome bro title tuesday is this you get
your you get some real play against the big boys
everybody you're playing is titled so you can't
you know sometimes you just can't pass that up
that was very nice tactics here b7 is hanging
whoa there is a lot of checks lots of stuff
going on here maybe not lots of checks but
there's a check down here this knight's hanging
looks everywhere to very deceiving though this
might not be that bad it's actually zeros as you
see the engine is like slightly better for this
person but i believe it is zeros as well there is
no mate surprisingly guys no mate king g2 and um
i can sidestep and go king h3 and keep my threats
alive myself very nice move he plays knight to
d6 make some trades you got to be careful where
you put your king king f2 with no checks there's a
capture two seconds on the clock man he's not he's
not gonna make this he living off the increment
he's living off the increment here living off the
increment king f5 king g5 there's a4 actually rick
b2 ring b7 and king g5 kg6 yeah this this could be
over canty thanks bro
appreciate that appreciate that yeah so one
second on the clock as we go back and forth here
check there's another check come on now
come on now what are we gonna wait was
the bishop no but both bishops were hanging
here both bishops were hanging he's living off
the anchorman you know that one second is he's
surviving off one second here somehow some way
it's so scary because when you got two seconds
you got to make moves really really fast here
and you can't pre-move wrong or you know you just
lose in that manner but he's down two pawns now so
white's just gonna win this one pick it off
here there it is there's the piece now this
should take safe oh not do that let's not do that
and he flags any flags because the game's over
anyway gg so i'm good this is round nine guys
round nine uh here we go oh parent versus bogdan
this one yup draw draw i don't ever have
to move anything he was also down a piece
as well so there's a draw nice game there that
one ended in a draw folks young kid wow whoa
wow look at this mate oh my goodness look at this
mates you see that there's two queens on the board
he let him he let him queen i'm assuming he
let him queen let's see how this happened
he cleaned check it was forced it was forced
oh my goodness how did this happen again check
it was forced wow man that was beautiful
not every day did you see mates like that
yeah this one's a tough one too can you can
you shelter the king it'd probably just go
back and forth oh he let you take the pawn
king takes f4 king e5 that's a lot of checks
a lot of checks here ideally you wanted
to go oh he couldn't play knight e5
yeah you want to get the rook back here and play
and get the knight on f7 and mate on h8 that's the
whole idea here looks like they're going to take a
draw maybe though ricky won yeah he's not doing it
he's strong enough to know that's
the idea though like rick here
yeah he's just moving he doesn't even care to put
the rig down there now the king gets out man that
was like sweet bro put the rook there and always
try to get the knight to f7 as quickly as possible
another king's out
tough game now i think black could
win this now king's getting too close
king's getting way too close
oh my goodness oh my goodness jasper with
the nasty mate wow look at this mate y'all
look at this mate there is this is like the the
day of the mates okay good day mate good day mate
right that's that's great that is excellent there
wow yeah what you're supposed to do is actually
keep the work down here so like work down here
you know and then like i don't know check you can
check me again but the idea though is to get this
knight to f7 if i get the knight to f7 it's made
it easier said than done and i also could like
go here too that's a check to look forward to
you know it was a good plan even in time trouble
that was a beautiful uh game though round 10 is
starting guys round 10 is starting and here
are two fan favorites we have min lee look
at him with eight eight points right behind
hikaru right behind icaru with half a point
you know it's only a matter of time for where
he just says gm by his name nasty this is a
family channel that's right man come on g day
mate you know grizzly foot come on now that
was beautiful can't you put in work lately you
already know elephant bush just his life life is
chess bro queen d2 defending b2 what happened
let's actually see this out of the opening
okay so you know hikaru with min lee they play
actually quite often so you won't see probably the
regular stuff you won't see probably the regular
stuff actually yeah let's get some updated scores
here here we go guys updated scores eight and a
half for karu and eight for dang joe bava chobava
going off too look at him eight out of nine jaba
came out of nowhere bogdan with eight out of nine
uh min lee with eight out of nine parham eight out
of nine i'm not sure who this one is the jurabek
yourself though big boy chess today bishop g4
hitting f3 knights question is what do we do
bishop b2 knight d2 queen i think the queen and
i know the queen feels extremely misplaced on d2
like how do you develop your knight do
you go to a3 but you can't go back to c2
so i don't know about this game for men
lee right now black actually has a very
excellent position bishop outside the pawn chain
okay usually if it's locked in it's more like
french type structures and this is a french
type structure but this is like a good french
if anyone if you think about the french defense
this is a very good french and somebody says
london in the chat this looks like a bad
london right with the queen on d2 somehow
you got a very bad london system with white but
with black somehow you got a very good french
because in the french the bishop's usually bad
but instead it's actually outside the pawn chain
and the queen putting pressure
exerting pressure on the center as well
some type of good french
black's doing good usually in this type of
position blacks black looks to play very solid
trades and end games not afraid of end games at
all james who are you rooting for oh absolutely
hikaru gar was a beast man this is great
watching car will play i'm not a fan of
in particular this setup of course he's going
for but i'm a fan of fincado with my bishop on g7
i love the hyper accelerated dragon
i played that for like five years
and then uh now i'm kid for life kings indian
defense so bishops on g7 i'm a fan of them big
fan of a bishop on g7 lots of experience with
that so when he plays it i'm like watching the
entire game trying to pick something up what is
he doing here because you get to learn you get
to learn when you're watching car or you should
try to learn when you're watching hikaru or any
strong player and see what you can take from
it pawn takes in b4 looks pretty good a3 b4
he actually just takes and gets rid of it knight
b3 said i'm going to the d4 square that's where
i'm headed knight f3 knight b3 same thing and
he plays here i'm headed for the c4 square
to attack your pawns and if you push him it makes
him kind of weak and he plays brick b1 instead
put the knight back on d6 maybe playing
e5 maybe black has a great position though
more like a carol khan type structure here
scandinavian type positions great structure
it's funny what do you play versus e4 dragon
because no k id yeah i used to play a little
bit of modern actually but um i play uh i
play an accelerated stretch took off i'm
just going to leave it there and accelerate it
stretching the cough that's all i'm going to say
that's all i'm going to say it's my
favorite opening right now it's e4
he says something how long about yeah the
uh accelerated dragon the accelerated dragon
was with hyperx other dragon was really fun to
play so b5 oops queen d4 takes which way are we
taking rick takes he says keep it open black's
doing everything in their power they're doing
everything they're supposed to do with the black
pieces here get the bishop outside the pawn chain
trade the bishop and then go into an end game and
play on the queen side also check this guys your
pawn structure tells you where you should play and
your pawn structure pointing this way which means
you're usually strongest on this side of the board
where hikaru is playing at strategically mastering
doing great no problems here but it does take time
it does take time and these are slow positions not
my cup of tea i'm an attacking aggressive player
i love towel type positions sacking mating and
gambits my kind of stuff you know my favorite kind
of chest is a gambit that has been hit thoroughly
with the engine and looked through and combed
through very finely that's how that's why i came
up with the c3 cecil for the keel it's very nice
different than the regular c3 cecilia canty plays
the jar jar gambit we might we might make up one
that'd be funny i'll make up something g5 takes
takes knight f3 probably uh he plays rick h4 nice
move playing for rick h1 rick hey maybe one of the
force moves he plays knight f7 instead because
if i check you if you do get this check you
can't do anything further than just checking me
because i have the h8 square cover by the knight
b4 is now a possibility plays e5 look at this pawn
mass beautiful sensor for black here even though
it's zeros as a human looking at this this
is definitely not zeros definitely not zeros
h4 early on you play h5 anyway pip and
chuck you can play h5 early if they do that
you can page fine
evil d4 e4 it happens it will happen mean it'd be
okay though just just work on your game every day
and not analyze your games look at stuff look
at grand master games i think he had e4 in there
but that just yeah these pawns are too strong
anyway so probably not these pawns are extremely
strong black is gonna be the one pushing for more
but it is zeros right here as you see he's just
kind of making moves moving back and forth trying
to figure out whatever he can pawn structure while
it is right white's pawn structure structure's
garbage but i mean and not even garbage it's
just this one's weak and these are but this one's
weak you know it's kind of weird a4 can freeze all
these two pawns so it's different different but it
is zeros i mean it's been zeros for a while here
hikaru may not be able to take another draw i
mean he can if he wants to but how does that hurt
him in the standings this is the standings right
now yeah and he cargo has what eight and a half
and he draw that would that would that would put
him in first or that would be a tie for first
nine points parham and joe baba are both with
nine points guys nine out of ten i mean jeez
9 out of 10 in this field come on have you ever
tried disgust gaming i'm playing it and i love it
absolutely i got a youtube series i have like
five i don't know how many videos i probably
got more than five i think like 10 videos on my
youtube channel about the scotch gambit absolutely
rook d8 takes 95 94. oh this nice been playing
min i mean you you expect that from in any
anyway but min is playing right now you can't
move the rook i mean tonight actually you can
he could play king g5 so he calculates so fast the
something it's just really unfair sometimes that
hikaru calculates so fast and now he's losing
completely lost after that move completely lost
wow
you just have to laugh at this it
hurts it hurts to see sometimes
it does it hurts playing so good playing so well
and then just saw the building and jumped off it
like uh they hurts that hurts z kid in fair
chess that's uh zertz i think that's steven
ooh oh no this nice defending f2 for some reason
we thought mate was there yeah that hurt that hurt
canty cargo fan boy absolutely everybody should be
a car with him but at least of the game you know
you have to realize his game is just solid and
if he plays what you play and carl plays the um
he plays kings inn in defense and uh he came
to detroit actually i'm here in michigan
and he had a simul here and i had dinner with
him so it was pretty cool to hang out with him
uh yeah i mean knight at four just check and
go back to e2 bro don't make this too hard
somebody's gonna blunder somebody's gonna blunder
at this rate somebody's gonna blunder they are
not trying to draw this game and there it is
there it is something happened there's a pawn
gave a pawn up oh he couldn't
take on g6 let's see if he takes
takes takes okay this is a draw draw like a
draw for real draw like a for real for real draw
there we go there we go there we go there we go
perfect that's a draw i'll have a sitting here
all day waiting on that game this one right here
though yeah this is a draw too as soon as you move
the rook this is more of a fill the door type
position doing great here yeah he's doing great
he has all the space he needs to check you can't
create a bridge you can't block with the brook
he just keeps checking them very
good very good technique there
that was good technique and this is
the last game here and this one's
another draw here all we got all
we do is shuffle here all we do is
shuffle okay you covered the guy in first
place yeah all you do is shuffle there
you guys it's a draw it's a draw it's a draw here
let's see how long we sit here well it takes 50
moves right 50 move rule and you know you have to
thank chess.com everyone just staying chess.com
okay you know claps and all that other good stuff
because uh if it wasn't for the 50 move rule
if it wasn't for the 50 move rule
they would probably get up to like
you know two hours on time because you got one
second increment pre-move it and keep pre-moving
and keep moving until you get all this
time where you can just sit and think
and do nothing until somebody takes
a draw if they even want to take one
and there it is they took a draw it was like
all right cool everybody's watching our game now
because we're at the last game let's just end
this and that was around 10 guys let's take
a look at the standings we got one more round
here and he karu is still in first place nine
and a half the only one running away with the
whole tournament with a half a point more guys
half a point more well let's check out the final
game here we definitely have to check this out
hey carlo versus parham here very strong play
and we are going to see the roy lopez berlin
actually let's see if we get a berlin and if we do
we probably gonna go to sleep right here right now
everybody just go to sleep wake up when the
game's over and there's a castle there rookie
one d4 perfect not the boring boring stuff not the
boring boring stuff more of the aggressive stuff
i think he says that come that's right man berlin
is a resident sleeper yep
oh absolutely come on now
go to sleep everybody that's it that's how they
gonna do us that's how they gonna do us right
that's how they gonna do us right here they're
gonna hit us with the berlin and just take a draw
that's how they did this right here
man they really did this like this
i know i know right i know it was a
draw you drew a 20 moves last i know
you want that draw so quick oh man boring
was smart yeah if you see right here you
got 10 out of 11. so i mean that's going
to actually shoot nine and a half out of 11
10 out of 11. so he clears first i
mean there's nobody that can catch
him that's why he took it can't fall
guarantee money yet he actually gets
like first first like or he's maybe tie breaks
he might be somewhere else off tie breaks but
i mean 10 points is is the top score 10 out of 11.
no losses he took two draws i mean amazing chess
amazing chess well let's look at
uh something else then other games
i mean i really wanted to see uh some something
else there and i was excited to watch this and
then they was like oh yeah draw bro what what you
mean draw it's okay though it's guaranteed money
okay the ad lasts longer than the draw did
funny game that was a funny queen e2 and
then i'm down in exchange i knew i was like do
something look wrong joe bava here did he like
sacrifice this exchange or like he lost this
exchange let's look at compensation did he get
anything for it three pawns three pawns six pawns
and five pawns so he got a pawn for the exchange
and maybe a bishop i mean a nice slight square
bishop where he's bad on light squares his
king can go to dark squares which we kind of
have kind of have covered with the queen here
it doesn't seem like enough compensation but
engine thinks that it's about equal it's about
equal depends on tie breaker wins if jabal wins
yes that's right that's right that is correct
can't take the knight and e5 you found pawn well
you know what that was an idea that is an idea
and there's an idea you have to be careful with
that though the more that comes off like the heart
the harder it is for you to really create some
kind of counter play you don't want to get to a
position where you have a night versus work that
would be disastrous you have to be careful with
the material you do choose to do to give up queen
e2 may be going back bishop g4 is a move isn't it
bishop e4 is one too
yeah you want bishop before hard position i mean
i'm down some material so ricky five it's going
to be hard maybe king h1 to try to play f4 and
if rook here bishop d5 you play g3 king g2 is
the intention i'm assuming maybe moving to bishop
but i think king g2 is what he wants to do play f4
king g7 getting off the light squares there
it is king to g2 because you wanted to
step out of the pin now we can play f4 it's
a risky move but this rook is very short on
spaces he plays knight d2 knight c4 is the
intention here forking the queen in the row
again the rook is very short on spaces here f4
rookie six now he plays knight f3 instead hitting
the rook black is starting to close in on this
position unless she flags him no way jabba wins
unless he flags him no way joe
baba wins this when he says
you know i mean hey i think it's double
edged i'll say that it's double edged
because he does have a chance deal but it's a
hard position with that inquiry that require
requires like it really requires there's no
in between it requires you to be precise here
don't give up anything and play the best moves
you can possibly find because you're down in
exchange a whole exchange here this isn't any
playing 2966 rated here gm here with eight and
a half points well no he has nine job has nine you
know how good he is but still oh yikes that was a
sweet move guys did you see that oh my goodness
that was beautiful and then he takes on b4
dang that was sweet and he could play bishop
before and then bishop takes b7 is the idea hit
the rook get this pawn and try to queen still got
some comp yeah that was sweet bro knight before
it i mean like that tactics win games until suda
says all the time tactics win games that was a
beautiful tactic now he liquidated and remember
what we talked about you don't want to trade as
much because you don't want to get down to a
position whereas bishop and rook versus your
pieces if you want to at least keep the rook on
try to snag a few more pawns and then you might
be okay trading the bishop now this is beautiful
so far i wonder if he could push it anyway
you go what if you just push the pawn what is it i
don't think there's no issues king e8 then rick c7
king yeah rick c7 king d8 oh you can't take
on e7 huh yeah that wouldn't work okay b3
now he can't push he's making it very
hard for him this was a very nice move
intending stuff like work to b4 even trying to
get my rook to the seventh rank or second rank
capture this one and queen before you do black's
actually closer to queen and then white is
black's actually uh better than what it
is tell me how it's puzzle rush kicking
yeah can i buy my hat from can you buy it
oh this hat that's not a movie you can get
it from my channel this uh this is my channel
my twitch channel it's under the march thing
yeah like he did exactly that right he's trying
to queen before oh wait a second wait a second
that was nice joe bava pushing tight look at
joe bob out here swinging oh that was a good
move too if you queen i just take it i mean good
move after good move guys they have came to play
today big boy chess in every area he takes it
he just says all right cool whatever whatever
right so now he got the exchange back oh he can't
go there yeah bishop a2 though here's this one
bishop a2 helps him you can't he can just go
bishop too yeah there you go bishop a2 you he
could try to diverge like you know get him off
but that's not going to work takes takes and
now look at joe bible coming back to draw the game
with nine and a half he's going to be right under
hikaru great job that was excellent the e-ball bar
yeah apparently the right work before joe obama
has something there yeah it's tough especially
oh wait a second we're looking for mate threats
has he made it he's it feels like he's close
to made it kingji no can you do that work okay
wow wow man job is not getting a break here
bro he just can't get a break man i mean this
is still a draw this is still a draw guys but
now you have to be even more technical here
this is still a draw watch the technique you
can even take this there it is and in opposition
in front of the pawn straight back straight
back opposition in front of the pawn
straight back opposition in
front of the pawn straight back
straight up back
opposition in front of the pawn and there you
go every time every time and they gotta draw
that's a draw there is there any more games mini
um maybe black wins
yeah maybe black wins guess
the move 100 you already know
knockout was sweating there java hat no
that wasn't oh you man yeah yeah yeah
yeah you know for the prize
money maybe splitting it
oh he lost that dang he lost that yeah well
yeah yeah we knew black was winning though
he had this and then the knight f4 ends it
seals the deal you can't stop all the pawns
cool we got a few more games here here's our
parent oh we got another draw another draw here
i feel a swindle coming though nope
okay not maybe it's not this game man
this is a draw this is a draw you see a zeros it
and now let's say this it's supposed to be a draw
okay so let's watch
let's watch it's supposed to
be a draw guys there it is
50 move rule okay thanks chess.com once again
oh wow oh let's get this off the screen right
now let's get this off the screen i'm sorry oh
my goodness this one right here another draw how
do you get two king and knight games like this
like king knight rook versus rook i wonder if
they hit the 50 moves oh they're getting close
they're getting close they're at move 116 now
theoretically yeah sounds like a basketball drill
straight back opposition that was funny sounds
like a basketball drill all right guys and that
is title tuesday title tuesday another tuesday
double the prices here guys check it check
out the winners here of title tuesday you can
check the final scores there on the side guys
pretty awesome um yeah carl congratulations to
ikaru and joe baba second place all the way down
uh third place as well guys but
we also have some other prizes
just so you guys can check here if you see first
place 750 seven second place is 600 third place
is 500 fourth place is four all the way down
through seventh place a hundred dollars there
then you have the highest finished female
highest rated finished female or highest
placed second highest finished female and
the best streamer whoever streamed it guys
that's going to be fun too man so this again was
the format if you guys missed it it was 11 rounds
today three minutes one second increment and we're
gonna have it every single tuesday here every
single tuesday here at title tuesday guys so um we
enjoyed it i hope you guys have a good one stick
around for the raid we should be rating someone
guys and i will see you guys on the next one
please show us your sorcery once more prefer
maiden guys how many times do i have to tell
you it's not sorcery it's on juno the mystical
slab of divine enlightenment your king holds
the wealth of the land that you work so hard
to harvest that you get so little in return
with on juno you can get more on your
deposits i have no idea what any of that means
your king is greedy he could let you earn more but
he doesn't believe you have a choice yeah we want
more coin we want more coins we want more coin
perfect i think you guys are starting to get it
yes it is the witch oh i don't think they like me
not only do the big banks hoe is the only interest
you could build with your deposits they also crash
you with absurd fees that nest in billions of
dollars every year oh shut up you don't know what
you're doing we didn't spread the curse across
all the land my lord she showed us the light
she's a witch wish as a digital banking platform
on juno keeps its costs low there are no hidden
fees no minimum bounce fees and no worries i
don't respect what you're saying because it's
new and different and it scares me and if you want
to send your money around the globe soon you'll be
able to at a great price with no hassle the world
is flat the world is flat right yes uh for sure
which way which will show so rich and who doesn't
love getting cash back on their favorite brands
i do love my cash back okay you're
a queen now oh wow thank you
our rain has just begun make the switch to anjuno